[Musica]
provate a pensare alla vostra infanzia
chi ha avuto la fortuna di correre a
piedi nudi su un prato
era la mamma
chi si ricorda com'era lasciare per
primo le impronte sulla neve fresca
chi è stato tra i privilegiati a tornare
a casa con le mani oi piedi sporchi di
fango o appiccicati di pece e com'era
era così bello da poter dire
indimenticabile se ce lo ricordiamo a
tutti questi anni di distanza ecco
perché abbiamo il dovere di trasmettere
questo dono ai nostri figli ai nostri
nipoti alle persone che conosciamo noi
che abbiamo avuto la fortuna di avere
questo rapporto così stretto con la
natura un rapporto vero non costruito la
natura l'abbiamo sperimentata in prima
persona
noi l'abbiamo studiata sui libri e basta
non possiamo sottrarci al compito di
offrire ai nostri figli la possibilità
di sperimentare lo stesso contatto
diretto è un dovere che abbiamo nei loro
confronti
ognuno di noi ha dei valori importanti
che pensa di dover tramandare può dover
trasmettere alle persone che ci stanno
intorno
per me la natura è uno di questi tutto è
cambiato
quando poi sono diventata mamma aveva un
pancione grande così e avevo un nonno
che mi riempiva di attenzioni anche lui
amante della montagna ma mi diceva non
vorrai mica andare in cima a una
montagna con quel pancione così è
pericoloso e la mia nipotina sballottata
di dentro
ma come mi chiedevo una donna incinta
non deve perseguire prima di tutto il
proprio benessere fisico e psichico e se
il mio benessere è in cima a una
montagna perché devo smettere di andare
a camminare in montagna
c'è poi chi faceva proprio del
terrorismo mi dicevano
a quando nascerà la bambina abituati non
andrei più a camminare gli scarponi poi
metterli già in cantina per fortuna
sulla mia strada ho incontrato altre
persone che erano delle voci un po fuori
dal coro come me
tra queste francesca tosolini che qui
sul tra il pubblico e sarà ba roselli
che virtualmente qui vicino a me con
loro abbiamo avuto la possibilità di
condividere un'idea un'esperienza che
poi ha dato vita una pagina facebook
attraverso la quale suggeriamo diversi
itinerari a misura di bambino nel nostro
friuli quindi dicevamo le attese
che cosa succederà quando diventerò
mamma continuerò camminare
mi sono detta inutile farsi troppe
domande aspettiamo e vediamo che cosa
succederà
ebbene l'istinto materno che
difficilmente sbaglia ma per fortuna
anche tanti pediatri
lo dicono da subito i bambini quando
sono sani quando il parto è stato
regolare devono stare all'aperto da
subito
indipendentemente dalla stagione perché
sam primavera facile portarli fuori
l'inverno bisogna essere un po più
coraggiosi eppure c'è una teoria che si
chiama arias terapia attraverso la quale
si sottolinea come i bambini che stanno
più ore all'aperto paradossalmente si
ammalino di meno perché i germi e virus
circolano negli spazi chiusi e
riscaldati quindi all'aperto da subito
per il bene del bambino ma non solo
anche per il bene della mamma perché
sarà aperto il contatto con la natura
permette lo piccolo diversi studi
scientifici di ridurre il baby blues
quella depressione che colpisce tante
mamme vittime un po di solitudine un po
di sbalzi ormonali e quindi cosa c'è di
meglio che fare una passeggiata in
natura possibilmente in compagnia di
qualche amica positiva è il nostro
friuli è pieno
o di passeggiate che si adattano a
queste esigenze
basta allontanarsi pochi chilometri da
quattro il parco del cormôr ci sono il
parco del beato bertrando oppure ci sono
c'è il parco delle risorgive a codroipo
e per chi ama il mare c'è il sentiero
rilke è una poesia tra passeggiata a
mare tutto questo tra l'altro a dei
benefici non da poco nello sviluppo del
bambino perché così come crescono i
bambini
così sono tantissimi gli stimoli che
possono ricevere sul cattano distesi nel
passeggino vedono le ombre vedono le
foglie in lontananza poi stanno seduti e
quindi possono iniziare a guardare da
una posizione privilegiata e poi i primi
passi primi passi sulle erbe primi passi
sulla sabbia è veramente un trionfo di
sensi la natura si possono osservare le
foglie che si muovono i piccoli insetti
si possono assaggiare i doni preziosi
del bosco i frutti di bosco le fragole
poi per i bambini un po più grandi
raccoglierli è veramente un giorno che
vale più di qualunque medaglia si può
usare il tatto per sentire le diverse
consistenze i ricci delle castagne
pungolo ma la castagna invece liscia e
si può usare l'udito per sentire il
rumore delle foglie ma anche per sentire
il canto degli uccellini ed è un tempo
prezioso per usare la voce a basso
volume per poter usare bellissimo tutti
quanti i sensi
da questo è nata la nostra pagina
facebook camminare coi bambini in friuli
e dintorni era il giugno del 2015 quando
con francesca e sara e altre mamme
abbiamo deciso di dare vita a questa
pagina
in un batter d'occhio avuto un successo
incredibile per noi non sono
immaginavamo
volevamo semplicemente mettere a
disposizione di altre persone le nostre
conoscenze perché regolarmente a ridosso
del weekend diversi amici ci chiedevano
suggerimenti per cosa fare e così un po
per gioco un po per scherzo abbiamo dato
vita a questa pagina da cui poi è nato
un libro in montagna con i bambini ha
detto dalla cooperativa mostra è scritto
in italiano in sloveno proprio per
valorizzare le lingue del territorio
perché come sapete quando in friuli
venezia giulia è presente anche la
minoranza slovena camminate
un'esperienza per tutti è un'esperienza
anche in gruppo ci siamo accorte che è
più facile camminare far camminare i
bambini volentieri quando si va assieme
e quindi è importante per fargli amare
la montagna fa chiamare le passeggiate
pensare innanzitutto a loro quindi è
accantonata l'idea di raggiungere cime
prestigiose perché ci sarà tempo c'è
stato tempo anche per quello
l'importante è e tarare i percorsi su di
loro quindi vinta la pigrizia ci si
organizza per prima cosa bisogna pensare
al al tempo perché è importante dare
un'occhiata ai siti del tempo in regione
fa scuola l'osmer e poi preparare lo
zaino per i bambini diciamo dai 3 anni
in su è veramente un'emozione prepararsi
da soli lo zaino quindi
responsabilizzandoli si preparano lo
zaino si mettono la loro borraccio al
loro panino il cappellino e poi noi
nello zaino grande portiamo tutto il
resto quindi cibo vestiti cappellino
crema solare piuttosto che la mappa
ricordarsi sempre anche il numero del
soccorso alpino perché non si sa mai con
i bambini e poi studiare un itinerario
che può essere attraente e che cosa
piace ai bambini gli animali quindi le
malghe
che tra l'altro hanno anche un punto
d'appoggio per qualunque evenienza
piacciono le cascate piacciono i ponti e
poi piacciono i percorsi magari un po
più dove c'è anche qualche ricetta dove
ci si può arrampicare perchè così si
sentono grandi
in tutto questo però va ricordato che
noi stiamo camminando anche per entrare
in contatto con loro non ci sono
cellulari non ci sono tablet non c'è la
televisione ci siamo noi loro e il
silenzio magico del bosco
quale situazione migliore per
raccontarsi per confidarsi per conoscere
anche cose che non immaginavamo dei
nostri figli
il tempo di cammino e anche un tempo di
racconti quindi giochiamo insieme
inventiamo story un pezzo io un pezzo tu
e poi raccontiamo le storie del
territorio
siamo in carnia e parliamo degli sbirri
siamo nelle valli del natisone e
parliamo dell'ecri papeete
e ancora le hagane i krampus la nostra
montagna è ricchissima di folletti e
personaggi mitologici che scatenano la
fantasia dei bambini
quindi diamo loro benefit dei benefici
fisici ma diamo loro anche degli
strumenti culturali per conoscere meglio
la loro terra sta prendendo piede una
teoria secondo la quale i bambini poco
esposti alla natura che quindi subiscono
un deficit da natura ci possa essere in
loro una correlazione con i disturbi
dell'apprendimento
quindi questa ancora in fase di studio
però è una serata negli stati uniti sta
prendendo piede è sempre dagli stati
uniti arriva questa teoria del filosofo
william che i bambini che in età
prescolare sono stati hanno sperimentato
situazioni di fascinazione quindi
un'attenzione in diretta
in un ambiente in cui ci sono molti
stimoli il bambino si lascia attrarre da
una specifica cosa come può essere la
foglia che cade piuttosto che il
torrente che viene deviato da un masso
per questi bambini sarà più facile poi
in età scolare concentrarsi su uno
specifico oggetto e di questo aveva
parlato anni fa anche maria montessori
che è la nostra pedagogista di bandiera
possiamo dire proprio lei all'epoca
quindi all'epoca aveva ricordato come
fosse necessario far vivere ai bambini
la natura ma pienamente non solo dai
libri e liberare i bambini da tutti
quelle sovrastrutture che la società
civilizzata ha creato che in realtà per
i bambini sono più ostacoli che piaceri
quindi maria montessori ricordava anche
che è importante che noi genitori noi
educatori noise
[Musica]
noi siamo iperprotettivi con loro perché
i bambini hanno una forza innata esse
sono nel loro ambiente e loro ambiente è
la natura questo permette loro di
sviluppare e di scatenare tutta la loro
forza e poi aggiungo io la sera dormono
a casa i bambini se stanno in gruppo
stanno all'aria aperta sono felici lo
abbiamo sperimentato insieme a francesca
sarà con cui ormai andiamo a camminare
regolarmente i bambini lo aspettano
ormai come un appuntamento fisso è un
rituale per loro io penso veramente che
vincere la pigrizia e fare lo sforzo sia
il più bel dono che si possa fare a ti
vogliamo bene grazie
[Applauso]